thank you guys really excited to be here
had a lot of different thoughts of
speaking about this talk recognizing
who's in the room you know when you've
been kind of living and breathing social
from the beginning it seems like a
thousand years ago 2006 when I was kind
of talking about the virtues of you know
Twitter things of that nature and 2012
such a different world you know these
things are more accepted and things of
that nature
but what I've been noticing that the
speaking quite a bit over the last four
or five years is that the Q&A part of
this stuff is so valuable because we've
all talked philosophically but the other
day really honestly all of you have very
specific things and needs around their
businesses or what you're trying to
achieve and so I really really
appreciate the opportunity lots I was
telling to the team in the background
that how I did so many conferences and I
try to tell them up front plate let me
do a lot of Q&A they'll really get a lot
of value out of that
and they're always like no no no the
presentations were so entertaining and
I'll be cool and then we do 10 minutes
of Q&A or five minutes and then it goes
really well and everybody likes that
part the most and then you know you have
to leave and you were right I do want to
do a lot of you name but I don't want to
just shoot off with you know though I
did hear that a lot of you have some
form of the context for me which I
appreciate who three people did not know
let's uh let's focus on this let me
start with this actually let me go in a
different direction let me give you like
really what's in my head
meaning the reason I love social media
and the reason that I got very all in on
it very early on is very honestly
because I believe in stuff stuff so
don't really put into context I talk
about a lot of very warm and fuzzy
things most of my talk now is going to
seem like it's coming very much from the
heart and it's very zen and delicious
it's wonderful and the only reason does
that is I actually believe that that's
what it takes to sell stuff going
forward in our world no other reason I
want you to understand the first thing
that I ever did as a business person I'd
like to talk about and a lot of you know
my lemonade story at seven lemonade
stands of it you know riding around all
that but some of you might know but the
real thing I first did was I literally
when I was four or five years old when I
first moved to Edison New Jersey for
that first summer before school started
all I did every morning was go outside
run around the neighborhood pull flowers
out of people's yards and then ring the
doorbell and sell it back to them
so I think it's very important for you
to understand that that's who I am
my context is I want to sell stuff all
I've ever been obsessed with is selling
stuff all I care about is selling stuff
when it comes to business and that's
what this is all history so we can we
get to me is a vehicle for business
because let's understand how I believe
most of you should be talking about
because how many you have plenty of
conversations or how many of you by show
of hands have had many conversations
trying to justify the ROI or why social
please raise your hand I figured so
let's start with this I'm going to give
you a piece of ammo maybe a story I
think that I particularly as well as
anybody of why social and here goes this
is why so comedians so forth
fundamentally no matter who you're
talking to no matter what business you
are whoever you are on this room whether
you're still white like I did
you're selling yourself with you're
selling books whether you're selling no
I do whether your stuff
chairs shirts pens know what you spell
in the world the only thing you really
care about them getting a mankind until
right now the only thing you've ever
cared about from a business was telling
the best possible story about your
product but there's a second part to it
depending that story in the most
relevant place for the people that
you're trying to reach back in the day
talked about years ago I'm talking about
cavemen they do blue crab on the wall so
you would see it and that would tell a
story and somebody was selling rocks I
promise you right and that dude was one
pieces rocks and think this is good
stuff that you should buy them for me so
all anybody in this room all 150 of you
have something to sell and you're trying
to tell that story and you're trying to
tell it in a place where you can reach
as many people fish 'only depending on
how much what do you have what I loved
about social is in the first year own
place I've ever seen so it was the first
zero cost platform that I've ever seen
see first of all let me give it goeth in
you know and I know when you name your
company so please don't get upset in it
I actually don't believe there's
anything like so I actually don't
believe there's such a thing I actually
think social media is the word that
we're currently using to describe the
current state of the internet we called
this thing web 2.0 just five minutes ago
this thing that we're talking about
what's called web 2.0 and 2006 we
changed the name of it and so what we're
really talking about when you talk to
anybody else what's the other line or
social worth it
please make them understand immediately
that what they're talking about when
somebody says to you I don't even so cue
media I don't think it's good for
business
I don't think it's an efficient way
they're betting against the internet and
anybody betting against the internet
2012/13
lost so we're talking about the courtesy
the internet the sites like Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr and Pinterest Minster
I'm not and I'm not these sites did
something very special
they took the platform that is the
single biggest culture shift of our time
and they connected consumers to each
other ah
we were living through my friends the
biggest culture shift of our time I'm
telling you right now committing myself
you know scary be blah blah blah
not one person in this hotel interrupts
I this room is really understanding how
big of a culture you have this is the
Internet is the biggest politician in
mankind this is the singular biggest
thing that has happened probably since
the printing press and it really matters
let's do a little bit of an exercise how
many people here by show of hands and
don't have asked me I don't want this
kind of I like this soon people mystery
after we connected with somebody because
of Facebook that they have not talked to
put your hands down
I'm not my bad Jan Karski I'm sorry have
reconnected with somebody on Facebook
that they had not spoken to in over 10
years Reiser yet
oh we're everybody how about 20 80
percent of the people in this room 90
percent of people in this room have to
be connected with people that they have
not spoken to in over 20 years now let
me play something that really matters in
sell yourself the fact that we have more
relationships today than our parents
could have been ever because the
technology is in place your parents if
they were more actually murder than you
and more social than you do not have
more relationships than you do not
because of anything else but because of
technology we are reconnected to so many
more people done Laurens number if you
ever look that up which we can have 140
relationships that's been blown out
because now we can have relationships at
the scale I can talk to people that I
don't even know on platforms and have
context of them before I actually meet
them because we've been engaging before
I got here so we can have more
relationship that scale right now we
have all accepted that there's been
major shifts in our world based on this
technology move everybody in this room
agrees that the music industry has been
disrupted by technology you know 15
years ago we bought CDs we bought a
whole album now we buy one song at a
time we pay dollar 29 we've got actually
back right the history tells me the
future it's how we used to buy music I
think a lot of people here can agree the
publishing industry's been disrupted you
know my brother AJ and I are flying down
you're not a heavily debating do I take
this substantial offer from
HarperCollins to land another book or do
I go direct to consumer because I can go
iPad or Kindle direct-to-consumer and
probably cover the masses how many
people here now read all of their books
on Kindle or if iPad razor yet crazy so
we put another 30 40 % right now I mean
only two years ago stop five seven and I
promise you we all get together on 36
they'll be the majority of you 7080
percent we agreed that the music in the
street has been disrupted we've agreed
that retail has been disrupted how many
people here have bought something from
Amazon please raise your hand early okay
so we agree these major issues from
happening by the way I asked that
question 11 years ago and a New Jersey
Chamber of Commerce event and nobody
raised their hand because I was talking
about taking wine to the air that nobody
raised their hand 11 years is not a long
time it took us all the time of
e-commerce to get 11 percent of Congress
on e-commerce last year we jumped from
11 to 14
you know big of a jump that is so we all
agree there's all these big changes
right but the one thing we don't talk
about enough at all they see so few
people talking about this is what
technology has done has exchanged and
disrupted at scale the way we
communicate with each other
let me explain there are some room has
been in this room connected in the last
24 hours
oMG lol
we'll be doing that we communicate is
changing every person in this room in
the last week has seen something in
their Facebook stream on their phone
from a friend that has said something
that looks like this pink berry
watermelon yogurt is delicious or I love
Snickers in the summer or things that we
would have never picked up the phone and
called our friends about and the way we
communicate has changed and what that is
the limit has brought us back to
small-town rules we were acting as human
beings right now bar or like we did in
the 20s 30s and 40s than we did in the
60s 70s 80s and 90s because we connected
and what's happening my friends is we
now have context around each other
at scale the way you did in the small
town back in the day back in the day you
because everybody knew everything you
did everything together everybody
literally everybody literally everything
but your mom treated you poorly that you
told everybody at the PTA meeting his
business was in jeopardy the waste all
businesses in 20s 30s 40s 50s and 60s
went out of business with like not
taking care of the end customer and then
corroding within the community and then
people not supporting him or her or a
month or two and then never going out of
business that is the way it went down
then we started going to the suburbs and
going to different places and we spread
out and that's why the big-box store
near Abbott as we started spreading out
big stores were able to capitalize other
thing that we cared about then which was
a close money to go and drive there so
the price mattered and we became quite
driven not service the relationship
credit we didn't have the relation
anymore the people change their
corporations we see the same faces
people in working safe business for 34
years we are now living in a place where
we can have relationships at scale on
the web and that is where we're living
that ship has sailed this is not bad for
a moment this is it we are human beings
and we live and survive on having
relationships with each other and we
don't given tools to have more of them
and stay in touch with more people and
do more things it is what we're going to
do and that would be the way it's going
to be forever and we're gonna do it
through different ways in the future
Google Glasses and Telep machines have
become robots and seem very freakin
weird but for now the current state of
it is we got some of you don't want to
admit it right now
flatout them want anybody to call me any
time they like if I need to get older I
will how do you say that at some point
your life raise your hand you do not
have cell phone and that's the game what
I'm obsessed with is I know and spend my
life trying to feel what I think you're
gonna do and you think you're not going
to do in 1996 I thought you were gonna
buy stuff on the Internet
that's why I went all enemy Congress had
stopped opening up the liquor stores in
1999 1980 I started emailing my white
offers because I thought you liked that
more than getting back sitting catalog
said it would be quicker and more
efficient and somewhat stuff faster and
speed kills in business in 2001
I thought you can go to Google more
often so when they had Adwords and
really cost five cents I spent lots of
money on it
I might get yelled at me and said why
are you spending $500 on Google let's
keep buying $30,000 full-page ads in the
New York Times and it's a limit
a thousand dollars a day on Google in 24
months just kidding you time in 2003 and
for I stopped blogging and I saw that
body was a way to communicate and I did
not do it because if you can't do
something you shouldn't and I think
that's a big problem I think that's
something all of you should think about
America is built a trillion dollar
system around telling all of us to be
better at the things were naturally not
good at lose weight do this be smarter
the number one secret in my opinion
about this whole game life by the way
that's what I'm talking about it's
figuring out what they're naturally good
at and over indexing on that I promise
you that LeBron James didn't give a [ __ ]
in science class every single day well I
promise you as a DNF student Brianna
12:11 what I was good at and I over
index it I started businesses at 10 and
11 12 13 and 14 and that's what that's
why I had 36 I had 66 cuz I've been
through it and by the way being truthful
to yourself hurts it hurts my feelings
that I don't think I can build Facebook
or Twitter links ups a method it hurts
but if you're honest with your something
you really think about what you're best
at I promise you I promise you
I think that I had that I think takes me
to the moon if I didn't taste it I can
taste it I can just smell when
something's happening right I can look
at something once or twice and like yep
so 2003 and for a new plot he was gonna
kill but I didn't do it because I knew I
couldn't execute and I wouldn't get the
results for the time and effort that it
took but then in 2005 something came
along it's called YouTube and a couple
weeks after came out this thing is big
because I want to ask my developer how
much would it cost me if I make videos
about wanting to be hosted in online
library calm he's like well a lot of
people watch it's gonna cost you tens of
thousands of dollars per episode not
gonna feel like a good ROI but that
wouldn't you two came out he came right
to me
I recast her people person oh my life a
caster who came in love with the Cadi
he said this can host our stuff great
they're paying on her baby I'm like this
cookies gonna go out of business
see sometimes I'm wrong look but what I
knew was this was it for me and in
February 2006 right after the holidays
of o-5 I started Wine Library TV I was
standing in front of you that is a big
catalyst to my career I took something I
was good at I did it faster than
everybody good I know what I'm doing but
I know six and I was seven when it came
out and I looked up in it's about 16
hours a day on it you could capture
people back then because everything life
is supply and demand my friends
everything I was supplying to man and
when there's only a hundred thousand
people on Twitter we just all follow
each other a little bit better
I kept rolling as a tape rolling looking
at things like Pinterest or rebel Mouse
with medium or all these new other
platforms if you don't jump and whale
rap
it's like you know the first ladies and
dudes that found the coastline of Turks
and Caicos you think this is going to be
big and bought that coastline
they won I'm so exactly we're having
please
understand this whole blog look let me
wait to somebody else approves it or let
me wait too it's big or this second
thing the lot of not jumping on these
new platforms and playing with it so you
can taste it for yourselves the thought
of not investing three or four days of
your year to spend a lot of time at a
new platform and realize how valuable
these emerging tech platforms are you
may stall into the next Twitter or
Facebook or tumblr so that's another
ethos of me I always jump and I'll play
you don't remember work but I do pleure
came out my plate I guess what I mean
looking around the devil in this room if
somebody feels the queen of Pinterest
your life would be good and if you
would've jumped on it for the years ago
and really put all in and spend your
time and didn't worry about the art
align that day the thought about
business is 6 12 24 month period you
gotta be practical I'm not telling you
the dream or the secret or any of that
stuff you gotta be practical
you got me fellas you live your life but
way too few people are putting in the
time and effort to build long-lasting
businesses everybody's looking for
shortcuts let me promise you something
texting is fast and it feels like it's
capable for shortcuts and so if all I've
ever done was one very basic move use
the lucky DNA that I got with intuition
to figure out the police's where I could
tell my story whether or not ecommerce
whether that was Google AdWords whether
that was my email service whether that
later became Twitter or Facebook or
tumblr and I just told them the best way
I could and here's the key for that
platform the biggest problem I see a lot
of peer and I've seen a lot about this
eventually
that nature you're applying the same
content across all platforms in a world
where Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr
and Pinterest and Instagram are very
different people are putting 4-minute
videos on Facebook nobody's going to
watch that
people are putting out you know pictures
that not high quality on Pinterest you
already lost people not thinking about
which filter they're using them and
every I'm trying to figure out which one
works the world we're living in today
and going forward and forever is going
to be figuring out the platform for it
you can tell your story best and
figuring out how to tell that story
uniquely for that platform how many
people here are on tumblr raise your
hands if you're on tumblr you're putting
out content
oh by the way this is sad because I'm
giving myself this piece of advice
because I'm not doing it right either so
I'm like yelling at myself right now if
you were on tumblr and 60 to 70 percent
of your content isn't an animated gif
you're messing up how many people here
are on tumblr and 90% of the content is
a negated gift and if you read you're
having to double checking if you're
lying and call Youm up to a million
followers
Elizabeth which is my sister and why she
thinks you're already friendly listen
listen super interesting to me how many
people stole my ain't 500 key no reason
yet so only about 12 min that hurts but
that's fine I'm I ate 500 keynote I talk
about when you play Twitter you've got
to stop back in like a 19 year old dude
and trying to close on the first move
right everyone in Twitter is just a
plastic blast come to my conference by
my wine glass II mean it's context it's
what I was just talking about with small
town walls build up equity the title of
my next book breaking news except for
somebody to really pay attention because
I've flirted here and there is Jab Jab
Jab Jab Jab Jab right hook right that's
the title my next book that's why I
believe should be happening in social
you need to create as much context that
scale and then when you go for your ass
why did so many of you come to here
either my equity your equity right there
was context it wasn't you've landed on
some banner ad maybe one or two of you
but you had context the light should be
here and that's helping sell and so the
funny thing to me is that we're living
in very substantial culture shifting and
the way we're playing it is wrong if
you're not spending seventy to eighty
percent of your content on tumblr and it
being an animated gif
you're not doing the right kind of
content for the platform and so I think
about this stuff all the time
this is all I care about the only thing
in the world I care about is can you
create enough context for people if
you're not at twitter.com slash service
every single day
and spending a minimum no matter what
you do I don't care an hour then two
hours a day on twitter.com slash search
and so every person that mentioned you
or the things you do for a living so
media isn't that wine dresses under what
yourself if you're not on twitter.com
slash search and you're in this room and
you
you're doing for a living and the
context of this event and you're not
spending an hour minimum an hour just
like working out with people you live if
you want us to be successful twitter.com
slash search watching people talking and
then just engage with them don't tell
them about your conference don't tell
them about this service you're selling
just build a damn relationship I promise
you you will crush Twitter many times
more than you ever did before but the
problem is I look at you because I
watched a lot of you talk replying to
Cannon and look I'm tennis hurts most of
you just want because what happens is
you're a marketer you're just be falling
into about you and the whole game right
now is about that it just is and that's
what you up to you guys click contacts
so that when you go for your right hook
you know what happens when you throw
forty five straight right hooks and
boxing you miss them all because the
person he knows is coming and the way a
lot of you were marketing I show people
right now is just that so all we really
care about and what I'd love to answer
questions about I'd love to get detailed
Imperial thing is can we handle our
punches you've got something to sell you
know the bottom line is we all do better
I would sell twice as many books if I
jabbed better he would have 200 more
people five language captain but like
whatever was no matter what the number
was you could have more if you have
better if you set it up you win more and
we're living in a world that you all
know this where the [ __ ] being
around the consumer has never been
better
you guys are cynical you know it as
you're smart especially is more it
doesn't really look for it
we've been marketing to more than ever
before going back to one last point when
I open it up because we're connected to
more people than ever before because of
Facebook and Twitter and by the way if
they go away will be something horribly
you'll be there and all your friends and
acquaintances will be there too because
we're consuming more from each other and
the way we talk to each other has
changed we're telling each other more
small things back in the day it was
supply and demand if you called some
money you had that one conversation with
that and even with your best girlfriend
or guys right you know an hour I know
some people can go a little Baba
half an hour right and you only get so
much in in this world it feels so on all
the time so you're sharing less
important things use of talk my family
and the big things didn't get down to
that you like Snickers or that did you
see that TV show yes that was something
but you do it more often now because of
that because we live in a supreme
economy in the world we're consuming our
content now in very quick moments
looking at our sleeves we now we're
getting contacted about products and
services from people we actually have a
relationships with every person
missionary spends money on things
because of a couple of different
barriers number one convenience we're
lazy if you can give them three minutes
it got by your milk you don't care that
you can see ten bucks and go somewhere
else you just want to fast the world is
so fast that we don't time kids family
bills convenience is king don't let
anybody could trick you we're lazy its
crap but the thing that we buy even more
about or equal or in the same realm that
really matters that we don't give enough
thought to is context when your aunt
tells you this movie's awesome you go
when your best friend that knows a lot
about wine tells you this Pinot Grigios
delicious you buy and when your buddy
says that that service or conference or
speaker or book suck don't buy and so
we're seeing my friends is context at
scale you now know so much more about
your friends and acquaintances and you
never did before because of the way the
world is happening it's similar to back
in the day and the game for you to
figure out I don't care what you do I
don't really could care less
I mean care isn't like what you doing
theoretically in business I don't mind
you're still and it's gonna be good no
matter how great that storytelling you
are and telling you
you know most people if your product
sucks crap you lost so hey it's kind of
good but good is a funny thing isn't it
there's good enough for a hundred
customers it's good enough for a
thousand that's good enough if you're
Apple right so we get those customers no
doubt is there customers for when you do
storytelling in the proper places that
have the most efficient return on their
investment that's the game what's
happening is there's a lot of smart
people in here who do I see I'm gonna
see yellow and all these other things
there's another phenomenon that people
are not talking about as we become more
cynical a lot of the platforms that we
all used to sell stuff for the last ten
five seven fifteen twenty years they're
diluting and quality how many people
here give me or to you though the far
majority of the shows that they watch on
TV that are not live please raise your
hand
Oh weird almost everybody just curious
I'm almost everybody in this room how
many of you in 2012 of those shows have
fast-forward in every single commercial
raise your hand oh all of you meanwhile
all my clients are spending tens of
millions of dollars producing them and
trying to shove them down your throat
and you're not even seeing it better at
here is clicking banner ads left and
right visitors can't wait to see what
the offer is behind that banner ad
that's what I thought but if you look
back in 1990 four five six the
click-through miss you on the internet
quite high now banner have some 0.06 in
you're a hero
how are you a hero listen baseball's one
thing you've got three hundred to go
golfing
2006 in here in a Hall of Fame now for
banner ads I mean we're the place where
that goes mail email 15 years do you
remember some of you might have kids go
to college at that time couldn't believe
you keep in touch with you anything you
got man we love that you love you coming
up you were pumped just curious who here
loves email that because here's Ryan for
the next thing in the world because I'm
a proud one myself marketers ruin
everything
we were signed up or an African signed
up for guilt free of living social or
guilt room please raise your hand we're
an almost everybody just curious how do
you feel that those services pin impact
you don't give a crap if they're already
over too much like spam
right you know why cuz they go and they
pounded you with so much stuff that you
didn't need your brain shut it off and
watching a lot of people in this room
sorry but I did it
the stuff that you're putting on social
is gonna be shut out and your matter
between context first to have permission
to sell it my book became a New York
Times bestseller Game one
because I killed it everybody divided
you say it again I competed against tons
of people and my book over in Destin
London the publishing world no TV I was
not shows nothing happened no people I
never built list to blast nothing I went
to my second channel so that I said it's
out I was warning me it's a 60 million
dollar business that was mother and I
just stopped and just tweeted me people
didn't and what I always don't say and
now I'm trying to talk more about I was
just produced a show that had a lot of
quality content behind it that also
supported them I actually I don't even
say this Thank You Connie my last book
is a book that could have been called
Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab that's why
my next book is gonna be Jab Jab Jab Jab
Jab right hook you know I guess so said
I might have forgot about the clothes
and the neon but that naturally
shockingly happens when you don't go for
it lady there's a little you know the
guy that won you over you you know the
guy rolls up in you at the bar at a club
or wherever it hits like 47 straight
times of this and so that's what's
happening in business way too many of
you know how you hate being hit on in
real life but you're doing the same
thing that shows you're just pounding
you're a consumer and you think it's
gonna break through in this world we're
getting pounded with messaging you think
you're offering or your deal or your
opportunities gonna bring through in a
world where Eric Schmidt the chairman of
Google last year said the amount of
content that we're producing now in
every 48 hours
is equal to the amount of content that
we produced from the beginning of
mankind until 2003 let me say that again
I want you to hold the hands of the
person next to you because I want to go
Mumbai on this moment the amount of
content that we produce from the
beginning until 2003 2000 seconds ago
the amount of content we created of all
the time mankind whole time is now being
replicated in volume every 40 a so what
you think your tweets gonna break they
don't find everybody it's not gonna
happen this isn't 1974 where you could
buy an ad a TV ad on happy days and 40%
of America was watching it and there's
nowhere to go and you watch the
commercial right no no second screen how
many of you watch TV without least one
computer like or phone device in front
of you while you're watching please
raise your hand
hold on either people are lazy or this
is the most over-indexing with people
who just watch TV without a phone no
company hassle watch TV with at least
either a phone computer or iPad in front
of them while they're watching please
raise your hand
okay how many people watch TV without
these devices almost everybody how many
people here watch TV with a phone and my
pad and a laptop these devices raise
your hand some things by the way the 22
are sick football all these counts um
it's true outside of live sports how
many people here do not watch TV rich
again I mean these are bigger and
growing numbers and all I care about is
where are you going to tell your story
back in the day 15 years ago with my mic
shop I was buying local commercials
because this winning Angele never let me
know that every single person who watch
TV every day just the way it was in a
couple book readers they write your
eyeballs and years of going to different
places and communications changing but
that conversation you had with your son
or daughter granddaughter niece or
nephew this is one of this real good one
that for three years ago
Hitler Ricky I don't care how you talk
to your friends this next thing but when
your mother or father call you pick up
the damn phone remember that just
curious how's that going for you
well they were texting with them not
because a little Ricky or Susie or Sally
were so smart technology was on their
side
we were living through a cold some poor
guy won a thousand horses the day before
the car came out he lost sir could have
bought netflix for 30 million dollars
they didn't think it was the right place
where the world was going they lost and
this happens over and over again I
promise you wait do you see what's gonna
happen a war over the next decade
they're scrambling now they're trying to
figure it out Amazon made a rush their
faces there and shipped you in six hours
and you're not gonna think why would you
go to Walmart or Target I can have a
cheaper faster and guess what
convenience I could have been delivered
to me I'll have it tomorrow worst case
so technology's gonna keep changing and
it always will one day every person in
this room I was doing the next 48 months
will pay for the baggage or different
things this neither credit card yes and
you're gonna walk into the store and you
buy something and you swipe you know the
rule I love it I look at a world where
all of this is so connected but I
thought about building an app called
better life where I make an app where
all of you just put in the things that
you'd like to do in your life to make
your life better get you healthy yet and
then through it being such a gosh darn
robot and so powerful it helps you let
me explain one of the things I would say
is I want to buy my wife Lizzie more
things randomly not just on her birthday
or Valentine's Day I want to just buy it
because I love her so much Randy it
would text me on a random day with a
length of flowers calm and I just click
it and would be on its way I would tell
her that I want to learn more about tea
and that's really important to me and
when I landed here today in Tampa it
would text me and say the number one
rated tea shop on Yelp in America is
four blocks away from your hotel looking
at your Google Calendar you have enough
time to go there before your flight
and so you should that's what we do I
would tell my app that I want to lose 15
pounds and what I'm running to the
airport now
that's game when I run there and I'm
hungry because I need to be here and I
go to Burger King and water to Walker
surprised when I decline your
refrigerator will reorder everything
that's in it for you in the next 5 7 12
years it just will it will know that you
like Diet Pepsi and it would see there's
one left and it's gonna be winter it and
who's that bad for that's really bad for
retailers because when it gets the scale
Patsy's gonna deliver it to you by
themselves and keep all that profit
anybody in the middle has to bring value
in business if you don't use it I
implore you to think about your end
consumer because if you're not bringing
value to them and you're not doing it in
the proper etiquette and the world we
live in today and you're not creating
context at scale when you're publishing
your stuff at office you know it's
socially do you like it you like
Facebook and Twitter Tumblr nobody's
seen your stuff if they don't care about
you there's too much of it being thrown
at them start creating context and start
allowing your content to have a chance
to be seen that my friends is the game
start hearing about the end consumer
instead of your margins and your
business might change start thinking
about retention all we were trying to
find more customers how about the ones
that you have what's the last thing you
called him just a thank you I know what
the answer is not often enough so stop
looking for more or pushing out more and
start maximizing stop hunting and start
farming thank you
get going and then we leave no time so
pretty pump right now it's let's do some
Q&A I really really really here's
something I want to say right off the
top I'm convinced given who you are in
this room that a lot of people can be
scared to ask 101 questions but we all
have holes in our game this is the
opportunity to promise you I will give
you my ball and I have a lot of context
and do it at scale but brother AJ I have
social media close to 200 employees now
we manage big stuff big clients I come
from small business so that's been my
whole life I have contacts across the
board
some thrilled to be here so let me
answer it for you so let's do it
hey hey good to see you yeah good to see
you again
but only a couple of weeks ago the serum
using a lot of automation in these days
to try to to get the message out so who
is just I said since the last time you
can I talk listening and well I'm
looking for content to share is that
your strategy yeah part of it okay
that's to me that's what your your jab
jab jab waits to nothing no no no
because sharing content is a right hook
to me that means you're pushing
something out
so you're still thinking in that way but
you look a step-by-step process we've
got 45 minutes to an hour of searching
is that a meringue puff to be honest
only two weeks right right so good now
we got the commute again no those are
right hooks when you're pushing you're
throwing a shot you're looking to create
value by distributing something whether
it's for you or other people I like
where you're coming much more with
sharing somebody else's than yours
however what I'm looking for is for you
to just create an actual relationship
with somebody if somebody's talking
about something you're doing for you to
just jump in like you would hear in a
cocktail party and just say yeah I heard
the same thing
isn't that nuts that matters more it
makes you so much more human
I've never automated a single tweet in
my life every tweet all 60,000 of them
that you've seen for me I've done by my
hands my gums no other person never
scheduled nothing no one ODM know how to
reply no auto auto [ __ ] autos for
everything else for humans this is the
most human time in business stop doing I
promised you anything that you miss your
question any of you that have had
something happened automated to you you
know it remember when you have emails
when email that smarter and all of a
sudden your name was like in a different
font they started losing her name or in
a different color and you know what they
were doing they just figured something
out to get your name and they look
different than the rest of the bodies
you know did that feel good it's only
[ __ ] they feel good you know they
weren't talking to you you were part of
a list so I like video telling you
definitely listen if you're just pushing
and now you're retweeting others you're
halfway home right you're definitely
doing something better but for me I
think you need to go out there still in
talking mode when you're doing that when
you're responding to somebody else
you're listening mode and that's you
need to start working on both years
versus the one mouth there's more of
them there's two it's a two-run game for
a reason go that route thanks man
I'm here hey bro your name John John
pleasure thanks man
if you were to start back down going
seeing what you see right now we're
going Facebook and Twitter to me a 100%
complete and utter no-brainer then it
starts getting a little morning because
think based on what you're actually
selling and what your KPIs are what are
the things you'd like to accomplish to
me there's very very vibrant waters in
Tumblr and Instagram Pinterest but those
are all very content any while that
jabbing I've been talking to you about
not easy to do there you can though you
can be part of the community and be that
middle jab that you're doing on Twitter
with retweeting on Pinterest is pinning
other people stuff on tumblr and it is
be blogging and Harding other people's
it's a twitter is so special twitter has
lost out of their mind
I'm so pissed at Twitter but they don't
understand how special they are they
keep trying to be like everybody else
when they have something that nobody
else can touch you can't jump into a
conversation on Facebook you're a
complete where if you do that you know
it's so special so just keep in mind
that those other places our places where
it's more content heavy you have that
quality content or you're just going to
lose but I'm very hot on those really
hot a new platform called rebel Mouse
rebel Mouse takes all your social
channels and gives you like a domain
they gives you like your homepage that's
an aggregator of everything you're doing
on the other platforms if you like a lot
of you are in front of computers right
now if you go to rebel Mouse calm slash
Aaron VGA ry Vee you'll see with us I
didn't do much this is just understood
what I'm doing it's created by the
founder to the former CTO of huffington
post and so very analytical
it's a dashboard you can do move your
stuff around you can edit it and
analytics to me it's got the potential
future homepage for all of us I think
you look at to it is I'm hot on that but
you know you to still have Socialcam is
interesting to me to every fiber video
play younger demo sorry try to reach
that so those are the ones that come to
mind for me right now yeah and listen oh
by the way the entire world is going
mobile and how these platforms tell
their story on roll overs laptop is
different so all the sudden most of the
comfort I'm thinking about I'm thinking
about mobile but there's an awesome
video I have right now for much of the
North magazine I love it but it's not
it's flash and half of people aren't
seeing it when I tweet it out there's
like it doesn't look at my iPhone
right so not only did I tell you you
have to think about different content
for different places you can't use the
same thing across all of them right
maybe for tumblr you turn your video
into three animated gifs maybe you take
a picture of your video for like
Instagram so like that you've got to
understand the platform but on top of
that you have to start thinking mobile
so there's a lot of marketing got heart
sorry I like what you mean standing
saying it's a pleasure thank um we're
gonna see web television you know web
shows like the one I think if you're
good you win I think my start while
every TV today same person I was then
that I went because the content was that
they would quicker could you know there
was just there's so many ways to
distribute content now I mean back then
like the thought of watching a 30 minute
YouTube video 2006 was insane when they
wired us completely and our internet and
cable is much cheaper than Google than
the network's and when we turn on our TV
you know it's a Google home page and it
can be any content I type in Jets and so
not only do I just get the Jets
I said why like I do in New York but I
would get a judge TV show that's done on
the Internet
we're all gonna be equal because the
platform just like what
Internet into the world the in you know
that hope phenomenon and music and all
that this wiring is going to take the
power out of the cable companies and
it's gonna make all video content double
whether you're on NBC or whether you're
me in a New Jersey office whoever's
gonna make the best and I care the most
and does the best job and scales and has
markets and understands they're gonna
win and it's not that the sided deal and
get lucky to a talent agent things if I
would have rolled in to LA in 2006 said
here's the pitch
I'm gonna sit in front of a camera for
26 minutes it's gonna be low rest no
editing and I'm gonna simply four
bottles of wine in front of me and I'm
just gonna feel and that's my show
I've gotta kick it out to hell but
because I didn't have to do that and I
just did it to the consumer they decided
the gatekeepers a key ownership their
dad we're all going to write the new P
holder is the internet it's gonna keep
doing its thing it got us social it's
gonna eat up television it's just a
matter of time you can only hold on this
thing is overthrowing governments from
dictators that have control their people
for forty years
you think this isn't gonna kill the
cable companies
i I am NOT what's your name my name is
Tonya I am okay how how does a
landscaper
down in Sarasota I mean how do they
market themselves for this stuff when
they don't have the budget to hire
something like him and I'm just getting
a question I mean I'm convinced that we
want to have a Facebook page I don't
know I mean what what do they do I mean
real basic feeling like this mom-and-pop
business yeah you know they they just
want to get the local people but yet
what's the best thing for them to so
let's go real black-and-white first
thing you tell them to do is look at
their email signature and make sure that
once they have a Facebook their Twitter
account then it's in the matter that's
in there so many people looking for like
getting users that's one way you're
emailing left and right all day most of
that heart even the landscaper down
there right make sure that their
Facebook and Twitter they'll get some
serendipity of some people following
them
right they don't have I didn't hire
anybody never wanted to see my life is
spent from 2-0 to millions of dollars of
paths I did myself and like marketing
and media the game I think twitter.com
slash search is the number one thing a
small business can do because it has
direct results immediately without
having to know or do anything but to do
that they need to set up a Twitter
account they need to not have just an
egg there make sure to go to this photo
in their bio
and I put a nice little picture there
your bio means the link to your homepage
which is what you're probably
storytelling decision to probably be
rebel Mouse yes I'm trying to invest in
it so they can do that and they can
start searching people start having
conversation somebody is saying the word
one in their general area they can
search locally on twitter by using
miracle in another zip code and
somebody's saying the word lon
and they can go innocent and here's
where they can't act like a 19 year old
dude this is where you gotta fight them
they're gonna want to because it's the
first time they saw somebody say my mom
looks like [ __ ] on Twitter and they're
gonna want to come in be like I can fix
that that is where they have to stay
disciplined that's where they need to be
bigger than what they are let me say it
again because this is actually a big
thing for all of you this is where they
have to be bigger than who they were the
reason I over-index fit it was I didn't
want to sell another bottle of Cabernet
I wanted to become America's wine guy
that's why and so when I saw somebody
saying what P nobody show should I drink
I didn't link it to Wine Library give
them free shipping I just told them with
the hope that when they saw that they'd
be like who's this guy look at my bio
linked to Wine Library TV watch a video
create context even more links to Wine
Library the products and away we go
three steps patience so Twitter comm
Facebook is absolutely a must
they gotta put a create a Facebook fan
page a business profile page and they
need to start creating content we all do
your landscaper has a phone he does a
nice job with the one he has to mrs.
Thompson and he can take a picture of
that he takes it and then he has to
bring down you a picture is nice but him
saying it's August in Florida this time
of year you need to warm three times a
day not to if you bring the value you
win that piece of content with the
picture has a chance that one person
will share it he's got six friggin fans
because somebody's worried about how
many doesn't matter how many he has six
fans because he put it on his email and
six people followed it or feels like
waste the time but it's not because
you're one piece of content
away from going somewhere right he takes
a picture he gives a good piece of
advice two of them sharing their friends
see it because we now look at dumb [ __ ]
that we all say to each other like I
need a landscaper they go back and they
give business that is black and white
practical that's what they should do
you're welcome donít look practical
right because it's really all right it's
not like Oh get a thousand billion two
hundred fathers and everything's gonna
be awesome it's not there's pages on the
internet that have 10 million fans on
Facebook and getting no traction with
their content because they're just
handing them what stuff nobody wants a
million little picture for like 10
million look it's like three shares AJ
and I are fortunate up to mid manage
Campbell's soup with a piece of copy a
180 thousand fans on her page we piece
of copy get forty-three thousand shares
sure you know you got pages you know how
many shares you're getting one zero
right I'm pretty value you can know what
how well you're doing real quick
I didn't Facebook fan page 70 fans we
have and figure out your user engagement
number if the money teachin with your
content don't waste the time I mean
they're talking about this yeah and then
there's engagement people talking about
PT a number is people that hit like
comment and share my reality is if they
actually watch the video as well or
click a picture it's an action you know
so any thanks
I'm not my name is Chris they're a month
and I wonder you master something about
that they are repeating over and over
the same thing from 2000 2003 what this
district was changing so from the
beginning to do that's between the
content thing yeah so that was the
amount of these stories videos words
everything we produce content
we're just producing what we didn't
volume then now every 48 hours
different things they're different song
than was written back then but the
volume of information it's so high now
because all of us are creating it we're
now all creating stuff every day every
tweet that you're doing now you weren't
doing you were writing that many letters
every day so it's a volume thing so I'm
not worried about doing something
different I'm worried about the one
thing I care about is doing business
supply and demand we're making so many
more pieces of information but there's
not that many more of us so every piece
of information is now less valuable you
know they'll never be a TV show that
does as well as mash because back in the
day everybody watched TV and that was
the hit show and of supply and demand
now the best shows you've got a computer
and a laptop and video games and all
this in your phone so it's a supply and
demand what I'm saying is your content
has to be better every show has to be
better every email has to be better
every picture has to be better
isn't it better ready okay so much about
social and now we're really moving into
mobile which you touch base on that
they're not competitive No so my
question is this where is your bigot
where do you see the biggest that's the
biggest thing in mobile and where should
we be looking in the mobile space that's
where it gets really tricky so Hill is
platform to because too much mobile is
just a device that helps us to tell that
yeah apps are important you know very
very important people to clearly
gravitate to an app culture they're open
to buying apps which is really fun you
know I just say over and over in places
like this content it's great contents of
commodity it's harder to charge there
were new books and all this other crap
apps have reopened that opportunity just
like
and so like that is an interesting thing
to think about but for me you know
mobile where the opportunities where we
are is impacting our real lives with the
things that we actually do because a
mobile phone is on you at all times
there's things you can do the things I
could do and would do if why my bikini
started today on mobile to help you jump
the line where you come into a store
like that's something about what does
something that's on you at all times
what does that do
I've spoken mostly about content and
information think of this more as
utility so what can you do that you do
that brings value to people that's what
mobile has a really big opportunity to
offer an index on because it's always on
somebody but I don't think there's I
think a lot of people blend to mobile
for different things
what was the harder air but it has its
own unique screen I mean people freaked
out when they could only have a computer
screen or you know tell your movie story
because never used the television that
seemed too small
right now we're here we can do it all
here and so when you're thinking when I
think which is most worried about is if
you're telling stories you're putting
out content that's whatever you're
telling you start making accounting
content and you're putting it out there
make sure that you don't use flash video
because half of people with iPhones more
won't see it so it's about the utility
and execution you know when you design a
website it's gotta be mobile friendly
because when people go on it and so
that's what I'm talking about
just real quick when you're talking
about text marketing which that's
becoming very very popular and you're
talking about going on and Twitter and
doing the contacts and all the so using
text marketing text so I opted into your
text platform done i text the board over
the stereo thousand and now you're
sending the information and many people
here Herman's disability part of a text
newsletter that they keep getting text
up raise your hand yeah okay but I'm
just curious myself you know but I mean
because that's just since that's
starting to become popular I don't think
so I mean you
that's just you might be right I don't
think so I don't think people want to
sign up for text these letters because
they're even worse than email because
text is our Holy Grail it's where the
marketers are away from and I don't want
them texting me [ __ ] that I don't want
okay to change the rules like I do one
quick question
so Jab Jab Jab right hook
Yeah right the hook was when the money
comes yeah why is it right honestly like
that's probably going to be the most fun
for me to write about right so I think
the right hook comes in different times
my place needs right hook sure came out
early he was able to put out people
quickly I think it depends on the moxa
it's a matter of fact guess what this is
my favorite part of we use this analogy
book there's been a couple of major
knockouts just from a jab it's been
stunning when it's happened but it
happens so all those that have to come
play it comes down to your business
how many jabs have you did when do they
wear down you know the son of the eighth
round right I mean how much you broke
the body I think it's different for all
of our business I will tell you that's
just the quality of your product
it's basically the power of your right
hook if your products legit awesome
needed solving a problem you're doing
something it's gonna work right so I
think the right hook time is different
for everybody I can tell you rarely is
it in the first couple of rounds and
very honestly I'm gonna have to be
careful when I write this book because I
think you'll be well and get a confident
and all that and I want to make sure
that I don't get people even though Mike
Tyson LJ I not use because everybody
here I'm telling you I looked and I'm
talking about everybody in the world at
least on my face in the first round the
patients in this world to convert
doesn't exist just doesn't exist